in der aktuellen zeit haben immer noch
sehr viele leute online unterricht und
wir schauen uns heute zum zweiten mal
lustige online school fails trolls
whatever an erwarten sie diesmal winter
zum maul aufmacht wird mich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
format augen 3
[Musik]
hat er online musikunterricht und sind
gerade liegt darüber wie er seinen hund
für den trockner park stakes ohne maske
auf oder
eine maske aus allgemein diese ganzen
leute die sich dann verkleiden weil
solche video gold er kann seine kamera
nicht anmachen dass ich das weg
komplimente
die professoren doctors say that fragte
holding und alles ja der so babbel
ich wünschte ich hätte online und böse
[Musik]
ja mir geht es extrem beschützen gerade
weil alle meine kinder matches
[Musik]
doch solche studien eingestellt wird
facebook kleinwagen er beleidigt sie
einfach internet das anscheinend
schlecht jetzt braucht er jetzt macht er
sich da in dieser online klasse noch
nicht kippen oder man wieder das ding
wenn du dein video calls mit einem
professor der kinder hat ja das verträgt
sich dann auch leider nicht so gut
[Musik]
ein typ und er sagt im online unterricht
ja mein laptop ist irgendwie ein
bisschen kaputt und anfang der lehrer
wollen ist der laptop kaputt ja meine
freundin hat den vorher benutzte ihre
online unterricht sachen oder warum kam
deine freundin vorbei liegen netflix und
chill menschen dahinter in amerika und
die unten schreiben chatten
ich lebte einfach
der wert 1 gegen auftritten lautstärke
gestellt
ich könnte mir den ganzen tag so online
school fans anschauen
[Musik]
drei wochen später
wir passen einfach gebühren ist heute
während des meetings alter wtm
[Musik]
professor ich hab da mal kurze frage
kann ich duschen gehen wie man noch
weiter
[Musik]
die wahnsinnstat bald mit den leuten
wirklich was er war cool wie der
professor dass der handel da ja klar die
duschen aber du musst die kamera lassen
ich glaub auch ihr wurde gehackt
aber ich verstehe nicht was daran so
schwer ist das einfach den raum
abzuschließen oder so ich es kann doch
nicht sein dass das dann irgendwie die
ganze zeit leute reinkommen in den
unterricht der sonne
der grund warum ich das video hier
gerade mache ist tatsächlich war ich
heute nacht von seiner online glas
geträumt habe allerdings von einer
online class die dann genauso wie sie
halt online in diesem video chat
programmen dargestellt wird in der
echten welt zustande gekommen ist also
da kamen dann leute den zimmereien
irgendwie ins klassenzimmer
beispielsweise der lehrer der halt
irgendwie total übersteuert gesprochen
hat weil sein mikro ihn nicht
funktioniert hat dann gab's halt die
leute die einfach keinen bild hatten
hätten dann keinen kopf es gab leute die
haben dann irgendwie so einen eigenen
hintergrund
es gab leute die haben nur um geträumt
beleidigt es gab auch auf sonne ähnliche
person in meinem traum
ja ich glaub ich das aber zum
therapeuten gehen
[Musik]
wie können denn schüler was bei also
hessen könnten
wollt ihr hin gehoppelt müsst ihr euch
leider zensieren wegen youtube werbe
freundlichkeit aber wie können denn
schüler was dahin mein checken die
lehrer dass so wenig oder wie
auch wieder die wahrheit ich möchte
eigentlich nicht sagen das ist die
wahrheit ist aber das denken ständig
mehr also mit diesen ganzen video calls
es gibt auch locker leute so
beispielsweise bei uns in der uni war es
zu beginn waren wir immer vollzählig zu
beginn des studiengangs dann allerdings
mit zunehmender dauer kam immer weniger
leute zu den vorlesungen weil man hat ja
keine anwesenheitspflicht und ich glaube
alle unter euch die auch gerade das
studieren wissen was ich meine
allerdings in diesem ganzen video
plötzlich wieder alle da und das sind
dann natürlich an meinen professor fragt
ob den habe ich ja noch nie gesicht es
gar nicht mir auch gut vorstellen wie
beleidigt einfach die beleidigen die
ganze zeit rum
wie kann die mittel fälligen das habe
ich in meiner ersten session auf online
sales & trading bereits gesagt aber hey
wie das nehmen sich leute raus so ich
denke mir einfach nur so er seit jetzt
gerade zwar einen online test aber
irgendwann in ein paar wochen oder
vielleicht sogar es bald schon geht es
weiter mit der schule
dann seht ihr die lehrer alle wieder das
kann nicht förderlich sein was ihr hier
abziehen ich habe schon echt extrem
respektvoll lehrern die sich in den
richtigen klassen 10a mit teilweise
störenfrieden und so weiter und so fort
auseinandersetzen müssen die behaupten
ich respekt zollen allerdings in seiner
online school
du kannst ja nicht einfach sagen ja raus
und seine autorität unter beweis stellen
so willst du wie ich meine ich stell mir
das noch viel schlimmer vor gerade an
der stelle ich das heute wieder jetzt
allerdings auch beende meine lieben
freunde wenn euch der mittlerweile schon
zweite teil online school fällt sie
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem video da schreibt nicht einmal
uns in den kommentaren bock auf einen
dritten teil hätte denn es gibt wirklich
extrem viel material davon und habt ihr
selbst gerade online video unterricht
schreibt mir das auch mal gerne in die
kommentare jetzt befinden wir uns
allerdings auch im outro hier oben ist
ist miley eingeblendet werden noch kein
teil der lupo seit und somit noch nicht
abonnent von meinem kanal sei der krieg
dort gern drauf es ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr und wenn ich
jetzt nichts zu tun habt weil ich doch
keiner hat irgendwie gerade was zu tun
dann klickt hier drauf das ist ein video
was ich gerade auf einem kanal
hochgeladen habe in dem ich meine
versuche nicht weit zu sagen challenge
gemacht haben